sur quel camp vous le bon monsieur le
président mais vous allez le démontrer
avant d'évoquer non je ferais bien comme
je l'entends ben non parce que quand on
fait un rappel au règlement le fond
d'endroits 1 sur le président cissé
dépeint mythique c'est l'assemblée
nationale je vais donc répondre aux
plaintes en ce sens je vais mise en
cause personnelle article sans président
je n'ai pas m'écouter monsieur monsieur
présent mélenchon enfin au bout de deux
minutes de temps de parole
ça me paraît un peu exagéré vous devriez
vous calmer on vous inquiétez pas je
suis très calme
oui mais on a l'impression du doigt les
questions à madame au tac à les médecins
motors
normalement nous avons droit de discuter
sur les amendements c'est pourquoi nous
le devions la main c'est un résulat raid
qui a été adoptée hier absolument nous
demandons une conférence des présidents
par ce que nous constatons que la règle
je suis ne porte pas sur les bords des
amendements aux hommes
nous estimons j'ai droit à deux minutes
de parole et je remarque le chronomètre
n'est pas en fonction et que le jeune
rémy hanf la surchauffe le silence pour
que je puisse m'exprimer sur ce que j'ai
à dire monsieur le président et le
chrono des députés de trois parties des
sénateurs de trois partis politiques des
états unis des communistes et des et des
écologistes qui ont piétiné dans une
parodie de lynchage la marionnette du
président de la république devant
l'assemblée nationale avec l'écharpé
tricolore
je crois à madame la présidente que
toutes les limites ont été franchies
j'ai twitté j'ai le droit tu t'es pas ce
que c'était sûr sur l'air de à cause des
garçons et j'ai côté oui à cause des
petite conne parce que c'est bien le
minimum qu'on puisse compliquer
c'est marrant ces scandaleuses que vous
faites c'est scandaleux vous attiser la
haine je suis très gêné que depuis
quelques jours les provocations se
multiplient et je suis même prêt à
entendre que la majorité petit prendre
sa part mais en aucun cas je peux
accepter les cris d'orfraie les
contestations venu de la gauche et de la
droite à l'instant de l'hémicycle pour
expliquer que ce serait la majorité qui
amènerait qu'elle j'ai entendu du mépris
et de la morgue
pas un instant je n'ai entendu de la
mort dans la bouche du rapporteur
je les ai entendus répondre sur le fond
ça fait trois semaines qui répond sur le
fond ça fait trois semaines que vous
essayer d'échapper aux débats que nous
nous voulons dire ce que vaut lourd à
porter aux français vous voulez réduire
au silence c'est ça que vous venez de
dire
pour lui le réduire au silence nous ne
seront pas réduits au silence
nous sommes ici par la volonté des
électeurs
le loup est sorti du bois vous l'avez vu
cette publicité d'axa qui présente votre
réforme avec la création d'une retraite
à points je cite le groupe financier la
baisse programmée des pensions retraites
pour combler cette baisse axa of bien
sûr de cotiser un plan épargne retraite
la voilà la vérité vous avez mes chers
collègues déposer 40 mille amendements
maintenant vous déposez 40000 sous
amendement par amendement
quand vous faites le calcul simplement
en prenant deux minutes le temps
d'exposer ses 20 ans de notre parlement
matin midi et soir 20 ans qui ne
respecte par le parlement qui ne
respectent pas les parlementaires qui ne
respectent pas l'opposition qui veut
paralyser nos institutions c'est vous
mais je vais le passer aux explications
s'il vous plaît mais ne soyez pas aussi
agité monsieur le président vous venez
d'inventer le 49-3 du président de
l'assemblée nationale avant le 49-3
gouvernementale vous faites preuve
depuis le début de la séance d'un
autoritarisme qui n'a jamais
lieu dans cette instance d'actes
unilatéraux qui s'assoient sur la
conférence des présidents de droit
constitutionnel réinventer réexpliqué
d'une jurisprudence
extrapolé vous avez vous trouvé sur
votre route à chaque fois que vous allez
flinguer est ce qui fait l'état qui
protège l'état qui prend soin et on va
vous emmerdez sur le fond comme sur la
forme sur tous ces sujets la mauvaise
torres disait qu'il vaut mieux s'unir
pour obtenir le bonheur sur la terre que
se disputait sur l'existence d'un
paradis dans le ciel et bien je vais
vous dire je vais vous dire comment je
comprends moi cette citation c'est très
simple pour moi la gauche qui ne fait
rien elle ne sert à rien
la gauche qui s'oppose à tout elle ne
sert à rien du tout s'il vous plaît
chers collègues
oui vous avez sûrement raison ce système
n'est pas parfaitement parfaitement
universel mais quand je compare mes
cordes je compare
quand je compare quand je compare à des
modes de calcul
quand je compare à des modes de calcul
pour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]